we don't strive to lose every game you
want to win but I mean to me this is the
way the team is always represented a way
to connect to my son echo fox was
supposed to change esports built on a
father and sons shared a love for gaming
it was the org that was supposed to help
validate eSports to a mainstream
audience with a sports icon in charge
I'm not here to debate the level at
which they fit and slot in athletes are
professionals and for a while
echovox was one of the biggest
organizations in eSports but then just
as quickly as it all started
echo Fox imploded creating the biggest
scandal in sports history I'm not
looking to go anywhere but I will not
stay in the business to the races more
money a lot of money to buy people out
of control that were threatened to
bankrupt the company people don't know
this story they would threaten to
bankrupt the company in the summer of
2018 echo Fox who may have started as
the organization that was supposed to
change eSports but at this point its
legacy is ruined forever
but before all the scandals echo Fox was
a team that helped champion eSports to
the mainstream and it all started as a
father and sons passion project first
time I played league was with Kyle this
was a new game that it grabbed his
attention and I wanted to find out about
Rick Fox was introduced to eSports by a
son Kyle who became obsessed with League
of Legends in college moved over to the
offices man walked in and I saw this big
picture on the Lobby on the wall over
the Staples Center and I was like oh
they must be basketball fans I went
looked I seen any basketball players and
I saw must be a concert concert yeah
they go that's the world championships a
league of legends of a sold-out Staples
just like yeah like if I'm in its oh
yeah no environment it's a quick thing
home
well can we get a tour and when Fox
decided to check out the 2015 na LCS
summer finals at Madison Square Garden
he fell in love with eSports -
everything about the sounds the fans
everything about the experience really
reunited what I've known for so many
years and on his way home Rick Fox
begins thinking about getting involved
with Eastbourne somehow maybe even
owning a team I get off the plane I'm at
the baggage claim and I'm standing there
meit's my son goes dad that's ratchet oh
I go read you know who's Reginald Brad
she goes that's the owner TSM oh and I
go oh dude they just lost I'm gonna go
say what's up
so hey Reggie is um I'm Rick Fox he goes
I know you are he goes hey my son and I
were just said master square garnet was
a tough match man I know but he tells me
you guys have won a ton of championships
so maybe be able to rebound from it he
goes yeah yeah don't you ever think
about being an owner no I didn't know
what that looks like like he goes you
should think about being an owner mm-hmm
like literally Reggie at the baggage
claim at LAX was the first person who
said to me you should think about giving
in and in 2016
Rick Fox founded echo fox now look that
all seems pretty normal now but in 2016
this was crazy Rick Fox was a huge name
and the first big name from traditional
sports to really get involved in eSports
in a major way
this man has high praise la for his
teammates but also their owner Rick Fox
it believes that the team will benefit
from his leadership it's definitely
because Rick Fox is in the picture where
he knows what's going on I mean it's
also that he knows like a team
environment and how it like it's really
good and how it's supposed to be because
he's been a team captain before and he's
like 1 NBA championships I mean he just
have so much experience and value he can
bring to like the team and I
value that a lot echo fox started out as
a league of Legends team after the or
bought gravities LCS bomb and they
viewed in the 2016 na LCS spring split
this is now echo fox just getting all of
them to die
there's the AC double kill seven zero
and five per keep deathless in his first
game on his new team and echo fox at the
day was zero but it didn't take long for
echo fox to grow into other games but
Shazam has not seen him as of yet but
he's wrapping back around and he gets
the job a huge a storm Suzanne and he is
fired up at this grab and there you have
it you to king of clubs are your Genesis
5 doubles champion Rick Fox's profile
and desire to put eSports on a
mainstream stage quickly made the team a
fan favorite by the time LCS franchising
rolled around Becca Fox raise enough
money to stick around in the league and
as if he was being rewarded echo fox
finished third in the following split
the highest they'd ever seen
diving is looking to take him down on to
the fountain not quite getting the kill
but the turrets are still falling and
there is no way left to stop this a 3-0
sweet back Oh Fox
[Applause]
echo fox had found its place in esports
the lien team was doing well and the
fighting games division was a juggernaut
know what that something we're going to
summon we gonna summon but suddenly out
of nowhere things started to go wrong
this has been my life this has been my
passion and I'm not looking to go
anywhere but I will not stay in a
business with the racists in April 2019
dick cerdo published a report by Richard
Lewis that revealed that Fox was
planning to leave echo Fox after a
shareholder allegedly made racist
comments and threatened Fox's family the
shareholder in question was Ahmed Raza
who had called former echo Fox CEO Jace
Hall a racial slur in an email shortly
after the report riot stepped in they
conducted their own investigation and
gave echo Fox 60 days to remove Rosanna
before they took action the 60 days came
and went but Rosanna didn't sell his
shares so riot force echo Fox to sell
their spot in the league so you know
they were very much looking at 60 days
working on us if you can get him away
I'm the situation well in in the US and
in general racism is not illegal so
someone with an economic interest even
company you can't make them you can't
take their shares you can't make them go
away right they have to sell their
shares yeah and or make a proxy or do
something to remove themselves from yeah
from the situation he wouldn't do that
he wanted to be bought out yeah and he
had it unrealistic he probably on about
you of what that the company was worth
on at rosada and Rick Fox went at each
other's throats and aired out pretty
much all of the orgs dirty laundry
rosada admitted that he had used the
language that Fox was accusing him of
but he clarified that he wasn't
threatening Fox or Fox's family he was
threatening to sue him because he
alleged that Rick Fox had mismanaged
echo Fox to the point where it was
his own investment it was not just my
dad everyone says it was just comment on
Muhammad
it was vomit and others and an
additional three million dollars or four
million dollars of new money that came
in on top of on top of my money and
we'll all call that in there and that's
how the company's been operating for the
last Peter that money wouldn't have come
in and that money witness been converted
one it was a default and echo Fox's
Xboxes riot agreement and Chu they would
have had no money to operate it wasn't
who would have paid bills will last be
much there was no money but Fox tells
the story differently according to him
it was rosada who'd mismanaged the
company and Fox was trying to save it
the president's asking me questions that
the employees are asking me questions
about what's going on yeah I can hold on
man like we're in a good position right
and I go start asking questions and I
start digging I see we not as healthy as
everyone thinks we are or should be or
should be yeah right yeah and I get
upset about that [ __ ] okay yeah cuz now
this is my baby that I hand it off to
you yeah and this is how you treating a
baby yeah back in 2018 echo Fox was
dealing with financial issues behind the
scenes so they downsize dropping players
from Cod League in the FTC Fox says that
those were tough decisions he had to
make to salvage his beloved team people
don't know this story they would
threaten to bankrupt the company in the
summer of 2018 and I had to put more of
my money into the company to get it away
from people that I'm going to drive it
off the cliff this alleged mismanagement
coupled with race honest actions forced
Fox to sue rosada along with echo fox
investor and former San Jose Sharks
co-owner stron sklavos who had actually
filed a lawsuit against box for
mismanagement the week before but a few
weeks after they were filed both Fox's
lawsuit and sklavos were privately
settled out of court
and it was in I think the best interest
of everyone around me that I care about
that they could put it behind them as
well so I settled with them and we just
parted ways and and agreed to just let
it be what it would be and there's a
brand and the IP is in good hands it's
not in my hands it's not in their hands
but following the settlements echovox
just kind of went silent echo Fox is
remaining fighting game and smash
players announced their own departures
from the team in February and there was
no fanfare no big goodbye posts echo
Fox's social-media went dark they
haven't posted since September 2019 echo
Fox was supposed to be a dream made into
reality a dream shared by a father and
son who wanted to bring eSports into the
mainstream
it was championed by a sports icon
someone who seemed above the corruption
and petty feuds that eSports was so used
to seeing but that dream turned into a
nightmare a nightmare that destroyed one
of eSports most promising orgs thanks
for watching if you want more content
like this hit the sub button and ring
that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]